[Musique]
depuis ses débuts renversant 37 2 le
matin de jean-jacques beineix au milieu
des années 80 elle est l'une des
actrices iconique du cinéma français
exploratrice des marges héroïne des
films extrêmes elle a travaillé avec
michael haneke marco bellocchio claude
lelouch et bien tu as cannes pour la 12e
fois de sa carrière avec lux aeterna de
gaspar noé une histoire de spiritualité
de cinéma de sorcière projeté ce week
end en séance de minuit
béatrice dalle et m'ont invité salut
bonjour merci beaucoup merci à toi de
cette invitation avec nous qu'elle
sorcières est ce que vous êtes béatrice
vous qui dit volontiers avoir cette
impression d'être une femme du moyen-âge
c'est à dire que déjà je suis assis
fasciné par le moyen-âge parce que je
trouve ça tellement austère malgré ce
qu'on imagine déjà je suis quelqu'un de
très religieux et l'austérité je trouve
ça hyper sexy j'ai beaucoup parlé de 2 à
10 argent tôt quand elle avait des
problèmes je me disais c'est une telle
icône asia c'est une actrice incroyable
c'est un grand metteur en scène il ya
une chose qui plaît pas et d'un seul
coup on brûle les icônes de cette
manière elle était traitée comme une
sorcière et j'avais dit chez j'avais dit
moi je crie pas avec la meute
on est des petites filles des sorcières
qu'on n'a pas brûlé sous l'inquisition
quoi c'est juste parce que tu es une
femme de parole qui l'ouvré qui se
laisse pas faire forcément le montre du
doigt c'est ce que par le gaspard noé se
sait que c'est aussi doux on assassine
les femmes parce qu'on en a trop dit il
on a peur de nous donner trop de pouvoir
par la sexualité de tabourets absolument
qu'elle lirait ce que vous faites entre
le métier d'actrice et le fait d'être
une sorcière et la sorcellerie justement
après tout il fut un temps où les brûler
ap les acteurs ni il ya des acteurs on
les enterrait la nuit et on les met à la
fosse commune mais c'est encore plus
sexy moi tout ce qui ne va pas et vous
êtes une autre fin quand même oui mais
ça a de la gueule quand même un de
moyens comme ça ah ouais t'as vu début
du film de gaspar avec tous les tricks
de torture là je suis un big up à tous
et sm qui vont garder
et votre mort rêver alors ce sera quoi
bein moi la plus zélée gon qui a jamais
eu ces mots christ crucifié et béatrice
dalle même s'agit été crucifié avec
claude lelouch sur dans la belle
histoire et c'est ça et je manque
d'amour et on est à l'hôtel à jeudi ces
moments jamais il ya tout le matos je
conseille à tous les couples une
crucifixion les gars jouent sur ces
hyper sexy et les réalisateurs est ce
que ce sont des sorciers
béatrice parce que dans le fil lux
aeterna béatrice et réalisatrice soins
et mais tu sais quand on a commencé le
film on ne savait absolument rien mais
j'ai envie de dire merci anthony
vaccarello qui donne une carte blanche
parce que c'est pas un film de pub du
tos et le directeur artistique d'yves
saint laurent et parce que c'est pas du
tout un film de pub sur la marque s'est
il a les moyens de donner une carte
blanche à un artiste qu'il aime
particulièrement gaspar noé et moi
c'était mon rêve de tourner avec lui
donc ce un sorcier
c'est un grand grand metteur en scène
vraiment chapeau sur quoi ça sur
l'intellect
je crois que que gaspar noé et le mec le
plus pointu sur le cinéma que j'ai
rencontré il est hallucinant et c'est
très intéressant ce qui fait sur la
figure de béatrice dalle en fête qui
commence quand même sa carrière aux
sorcières on se souvient du film where
comme elle occupe mon premier fils qui a
appelé la sorcière un magnifique et là
aujourd'hui on vous retrouve dans un
film sur la sorcellerie avec gaspard
nourrir ce que j'étais tout est là quand
même
l'alphabet tebbane quel alphabet des
sorcières gaspar noé béatrice dalle
c'est une évidence
moi je trouve croisé s'est pas produit
parce que je suis dingue de son cinéma
donc et j'ai bien vu sur le tournage la
manière qu'il a tourné
dont il fonctionne je suis une actrice
pour lui mais pourquoi ça s'est pas
produit avant bas il faut lui demander à
lui voir un super gars qui est le
premier jour j'étais surprise tu sais on
ne tourne qu'à minuit on attend on
attend et mais c'est volontaire c'est
pas du tout le mec sait pas ce qu'on va
faire c'est qui va te mettre dans un
état si tu as envie de piccoli qui
picolent si tu as envie de te défoncer
tu te défonces tu fais ce que tu veux
parce que c'est pas pour un truc
sulfureux si juste il vécut dans un état
particulier c'est ce qui m'a dit moi il
m'a dit avait pas de scénario j'aurais
pourquoi scénario est bien écrit des
scénarios pour les gens qui n'ont rien à
dire
bah ouais vous n'avez pas les scénarios
ben je les lis pas ça me saoule alors
quand je fais du théâtre bas il faut que
j'apprenne tu vas et les scénars
j'apprends monte exprès au lendemain
mais je me dis le plus grand scénario du
monde cite un site et un baltringue ça
ferait un film pourri quoi tu vas et
j'ai jamais dit je me souviens michael
haneke michael haneke quand j'ai fait le
temps du loup il voulait que gisèle
scénario on a rendez-vous kléber et je
n'ai pas lu alors on dit voilà moi c'est
très important pour moi
orgie ouest chez eux et on voit jean le
lendemain du jour après évidemment je
n'avais pas lu donc à chaque fois qu'ils
me parler et qui dit il a dans un sens
je dois parler de ça et tout je vais
bien endormez pas ce que j'ai vu le film
et quel plaisir de tourner avec un noeud
aussi bordel quel metteur en scène vous
avez rendus fiers d'une prise parce
qu'on est déjà mais quoi alors et moi
j'étais super fier d'un truc c'est
cherokee et mon mari dans le film est
une scène très très longue un plan c est
avec eux alors lui celle inverse
tout est écrit ou tu peux dire ce que tu
veux tout est écrit tu vas à la virgule
près tu change rien et j'ai une très
longue scène avec chéreau et haneke qui
sourient jamais qu'ils regardent qui est
derrière son combo qui te dit rien il
arrête enfin à l'infini il a toujours la
même équipe 20 beaucoup des techniciens
qui sont souvent les mêmes tu as acquis
la confiance et ils me regardent des
vendeurs barça wunderbach de michael
haneke mewa c'est la teuf tu parti à la
cantine me chercher une glace et tous de
toute l'équipe qui était à butiner
mais quel plaisir il a dit merveilleux
windows phone au goût d'or bat gaspar
noé sur le tournage de l'occident mais
je sens qu'il était hyper content vous
ce qui m'a surpris le plus c'est son
discours sur le féminin parce que gaspar
noé c'est pas forcément on pense tout de
suite mais tu sais quel soudry raconte
histoires de sorcières c'est à dire une
histoire de mais complètement et gaspard
et d'une délicatesse
je les ai vus a vu qu'il y avait
beaucoup d'actrices et je voyais comment
il prenait soin nous des filles en
particulier mais de tout le monde mais
il était attentionné il est
incroyablement attentionné comme il
prenait soin de parler de la puissance
invaincu des femmes mais c'est vrai
expression de mona chollet qui
réfléchissent sur ce que c'est qu'une
sorcière
aujourd'hui on l'attend pas la casse par
ben et ses bas mais qui sait si comme
beaucoup de gens que je fréquente ou
d'un seul coup il on regarde on a
beaucoup montrés du doigt mais pas
forcément ceux qui aiment surgit nihad
oreilles tu vois mais j'y vais pour elle
et elle est sulfureuse et quand tu la
connais c'est juste la plus merveilleuse
des femmes c'est un écrivain incroyable
mais c'est la plus merveilleuse des
femmes la plus délicate la plus
silencieuse que je dis c'est que le
féminisme des vergers dépense mais sans
tour de mecs le féminisme de gaspar noé
moi je crois qu'aujourd'hui on sait les
femmes c'est un truc de solidarité entre
nous tu ne peux pas ne pas avoir soif de
liberté quand tu es une femme plus
aujourd'hui qu'avant mais toujours non
mais là aujourd'hui
ben disons qu'on en parle plus mais moi
qui ne suis pas quelqu'un de forcément
militants qui n'étaient pas en tout cas
je remercie toutes les femmes tu sais
qu'ils se sont battus et qui font que
les filles d'aujourd'hui dont jouit de
cette liberté grâce à elle tu vois quand
on est lui quand un magazine ailier
marion maréchal-le pen femme préférée
des français j ai les mecs vous avez
prix de l'acide ou quoi vous êtes egos
magazine c'était vsd c'est particulier
là à écouter marion maréchal-le pen gym
et puis j'aime bien fine descendre je
suis un bad trip et tu as quand
même il ya simone veil nom simone veil à
la fédé chose pour les femmes
tu as des flammes incroyable tu as des
femmes incroyable talent est jamais
caché
tu as des modes de dengue qui se délient
un machin pareil vous avez jamais caché
béatrice être en recherche
lien c'est la prochaine affiche du
prochain rob zombie la famille le pen ça
fait super peur les gars prêt ou par
exemple ils avaient ce qui avait 10 à 20
la mouche mais qui ouvre le festival de
cannes avec des zombies mais j'ai des
frissons quand je parle du gibier les
ouïes traverse en fait tout ce festival
tout cpu les léger j'ai dit tu sais
si les zombies c'est iggy pop mais
vivement qu'ils des zombies qui nous
donne c'est peut-être un film de zombies
luz atteindrait aussi bas non c'est sûr
mais c'est parce que je n'ai pas vu ce
film de gilles mais je vais aller le
voir évidemment dans le film de gaspar
noé look cette année il est question
abandonné d'un tournage de morts-vivants
c'est une ré c'est une réflexion je
crois que que gaspar a vu que jean luc
godard disait que les metteurs en scène
d'aujourd'hui prennent tellement pas
beaucoup pas tous prennent pas de
risques à la cdc des morts-vivants mais
je crois que c'est dans tous les
domaines tu sais maintenant tu as plus
loin de baisers tap le droit de boire
t'as plus droit de rien
sans déconner tu vas % à pleuvoir vous
le fait non ouais je suis homme alors
bien sûr mais tu dit fyhn réflexion moi
j'adore les blagues racistes homophobes
truc parce que je suis pas raciste je
suis pas homophobe je suis pas bon tu
peux te permettre comme avec n'importe
qui même si j'en ai rien à
absolument parce que moi je sais que
c'est un gage pour les matin si je
m'engage pas pour les les gars je
suis pas lesbienne je suis pas noir je
suis pas fudge par veux juste c'est la
liberté non c'est la liberté de
respecter les gens avec leurs
différences et surtout de se rendre
compte de la richesse
de cette de richesses et
dans d'en jouir et de s'en réjouir merde
ou parlent de liberté on parle de
jouissance on parle de cinéma je vais
montrer une scène une scène de luz
éternel regard d'ensemble
oui regardez son devient on a pris un
mot c'est après lé 6 au cid
abbassi que de l'impro là mais à la fois
gaspard juste avant il sait que tu
donnes de pasolini alors une dit tu vas
me parler de pasolini mais sans dire
pasolini mais sans sans citer un film en
particulier et tu vas me faire deviner
que ce n'est pas aux lignes parce que on
a fait plein plein de prix c'est
vachement
il dit après on va parler de la religion
mais on va passer à des sites et jésus
ou implicites et israël on va pas et
c'est toujours comme ça alors du coup et
moi je ça va dans l'impro tu vois c'est
j'aime bien donc
et puis quel plaisir avec eux parce
qu'on est si différente avec charles où
on est deux femmes si différentes
et du coup c'est la crise de haut et tu
sais quand j'ai rencontré la première
fois charlotte je montre une photo de
toi on elle faisait la petite voleuse et
la can
moi je suis pour 37 2 on est deux bébés
est on avec jean claude brialy on est
nous tiens comme ça et tu as deux petits
bébés c'est nous catherine vous avez
toujours dit que vous étiez en recherche
absolue de cinéastes radicaux avec des
propositions il est dans tout et c'est
pas que dans le cinéma c'est dans ma vie
je veux des moments d'infini sinon je
m'emmerde
vous avez dit souvent que vous étiez une
actrice soldate qui réclame son
dictateur et même un peu au risque
d'être son goût dans sa voiture sous son
expression 1
est-ce que j'étais le goal non pas une
créature soumises attention mais
chercher mhf seulement c'est toujours
moi le chef ont fait quoi à la gaston ça
s'est passé comme ça l'empa les metteurs
en scène je parlais des mecs dans la vie
la compétence mais avec les metteurs en
scène moi j'ai besoin d'un mec qui sait
où il va même si c'est de l'impro comme
ça où tu lui fais confiance à mort parce
que le mec est super brillant mais c'est
quelque chose que vous allez chercher
aussi dans les films que vous choisissez
depuis la projection de job day by day
de claire denis qui avait fait une forme
de scandale à cannes en 2001 c'était pas
une forme de scandale c'est qu'ils ont
arrêté la projo et je suis avec didier
on est à l'hôtel joey starr
on rentre à l'hôtel se termine en tirons
garde pas le film on avait déjà vu et on
me rappelle on doit la projection faut
venir si leïla 14 dubai j'aime pas le
film est en train de tout défoncer
nantes a dit mme huff quand des cinq
coqs et les conflits sont là j'ai alors
là bas parce que vous jouez un
personnage de femme anthropophage mais
moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est que depuis
vous vous aventurez de plus en plus dans
le cinéma de genre en réclamant le
cinéma d'horreur j'adore pourquoi on
fait est ce que c'est un terrain
d'expérience
suis-je le trail avec toi rob zombie
ouais ok c'est dit mais pourquoi mais
c'est un terrain d'expérimentation pour
la comédienne parce que moi j'ai pas
envie
c'est pour faire des crêpes j'en ai rien
à exemple ken loach qui fait du
social et qui veut fait merveilleusement
bien mais tout le monde n'est pas ken
loach
si c'est pour faire le quotidien moi
dans ma vie j'en le pas du quotidien tu
vas n'empêche quand on y pense béatrice
êtes une des rares actrices françaises à
avoir tourné aux états unis avec abel
ferrara avec l'autriche avec lesquels
anno currin italie et marco bellocchio
jack au japon avec le bureau soit même
en egypte avec qui il a travaillé avec
le hesbollah je pensais de la seule
actrice avoir tourné que le hezbollah
si l'on reste de tout ça bah la femme
que je suis aujourd'hui merci à tous ces
mecs qui ont conquis la curiosité avoir
envie de me rencontrer parce qu'au
départ je sais que 37e ont associé une
créature de fil c'était mon premier truc
mais tout de suite par contre j'ai super
intéressé les musiciens on voit tout ce
qui est les rockeurs leur garde mais
c'est la mienne aussi donc ça va vous
avez parlé récemment sur france inter
maîtrise la précarité d'être une
canadienne du sans argent sans logement
perceuse et ouais ouais
pourtant vous avez débuté au cinéma à 21
ans ouais vous êtes très connu je me
suis vous êtes lacalle qui ont la vision
de foi
moi c'était mec aerosmith qui disait
qu'il avait sniffé un avion une piscine
et où moi aussi même si ça tient à quoi
et c'est aussi des compromis parce que
moi je suis quand même beaucoup de films
il ya pas de thunes celle des premiers
fier du cinéma indépendant et on vous
les propose l'aigle et gros budget l'a
proposé om et vous c'est pas ma came du
tout donc vous dites non ah ouais ouais
si c'est pour me plier
je me dis après tu fais du commerce
s'est pas critiquable c'est très bien de
faire du commerce mais c'est une autre
démarche
moi si j'avais pu faire le tapin mais
j'aurais fait qu'un prince saoudien tu
as j'ai pas envie de faire mon métier
bien moindre dans le film où elle est
quelqu'un qui dit c'est la triste que
dalle ouais mais ça ta vie puisqu'il est
méchant prod même pas mon truc mais
quand tu vois le film il ferme sa gueule
mais ça c'est ça elles sont enfin
regarder le si vous fermez votre gueule
j'ai envie de dire ça un peu parce que
et déjà et la fin justifie les moyens
qu'est ce que ça peut te fous de ce que
je fais de ma vie si mon travail déjà je
respecte les gens je suis quelqu'un de
gentil c'est une grande gueule on
imagine que non
quelqu'un de gentil et respectueux
maintenant si tu me respectes pas je
m'en fous j'ai de cramer mec respecte
moi comme moi je te respecte c'est une
fois j'avais dit
je vais traiter comme catherine deneuve
j'adore j'adore cette actrice cette
icône et je me dis une femme jeu comme
elle je suis une actrice une femme
surtout une personne sur tout mais je
devrais dire plus tôt et je compterai de
la même manière parce que moi je vais
bien de traiter en premier donc fait le
aussi ça va vous avez bien traités
aujourd'hui à super merci bien triste
merci à vous mellouk eterna moyen
métrage de gaspar noé avec béatrice
dalle et charlotte gainsbourg notamment
présenté sa milice maritaux et plein
dans ses anses de minuit clara 3000 ce
sera bientôt visible dans les salons de
clara 3000 les allemands andre 3000
d'outkast cycle a grandi jet parce qu'un
film de gaspar noé c'est toujours un
évènement merci à tous d'avoir suivi cet
autre paire citons tout de suite la
suite
[Musique]